all of our drug czars have either been
police chief sir or military generals or
professional moralists I think we might
possibly just be better off without it
hi I'm Ethan Nadelmann on the founder
and executive director of the drug
policy alliance we're trying to build a
national organization and national
movement and the war on drugs in America
and really are around the world I think
the number one thing is basically to
break the taboo on I'm really open and
honest dialogue about all drug policy
options including legalization
unfortunately it's not yet penetrated
the Congress is not quite penetrating
the state legislatures more and more
build people think it but not enough
people are saying it and it's breaking
that taboo putting that debate out there
that's ultimately going to transform the
consciousness of the American public
around this issue I'd say one of the
biggest obstacles is the pervasive fear
and ignorance that permeates discussions
of this issue from legislative bodies to
the American public I think the most
focused obstacle is the prison
industrial complex the drug prohibition
industrial complex hundreds of thousands
of not millions of people earning their
money off the war on drugs in positions
of power to defend vested interest
police prosecutors prison guards private
prison builders you name it I mean they
are focused on protecting what they have
they are focused on protecting the
status quo the ones who descend from the
mainstream in that world fear to speak
out so that's a major and well-funded
source of obviously opposition
I would give obama an a compared to all
of his predecessors going back to Jimmy
Carter I give him about a c-minus in
terms of what the country really needs
that happening he has pointed drug
policy in a somewhat new direction in
this country he did they good on the
commitments he major in the campaign
about reforming the crack powder laws
about legalizing funding for needle
exchange about pulling back on federal
interference on medical marijuana but
the budget remains the same the money
keeps flowing down the same coppers and
down the toilet on interdiction
enforcement efforts the whole notion
that politics should no longer Trump's
science he's obviously abandoned that
when it comes to drug policy so it's
been a step in the right direction I
think that the recent Republican take
over the House of Representatives is
going to make things more difficult I
think that having people like Lamar
Smith now chairing the House Judiciary
Committee is going to be a significant
step backward to where we were before
but I think there's also going to be
opportunities to cut the drug war budget
that's one area where Republicans and
conservatives in Washington if sometimes
been ahead of the Democrats cut the drug
war waste some of the low-hanging food
are some of this money down the drain on
anti-drug propaganda on TV that we know
those at work some of the low-hanging
fruit are the dare programs where cops
go into schools and are actually the
worst deliverers of drug education I'd
also point to Laura called the burn
grants which are unrestricted more or
less federal money to local police
departments that are then used to arrest
people for marijuana offenses and other
petty drug offenses I think a lot of the
money were pouring into the military and
interdiction we know that whether you
double or triple the amount of money
going into tree keeping drugs out of the
country it has almost no impact and the
actual availability or price of drugs in
this country so some of those are going
to make very good targets I'm even
curious about the notion of abolishing
the drug czars office I feel a little
ambivalent about that on the one hand if
you had a really good drugs are as you
do for example Netherlands it would
actually be a constructive thing but
given that all of our drug czars have
either been police chief sore or
military generals or professional
moralists I think we might possibly just
be better off without
well I'll tell you I was just in Lisbon
a couple weeks ago it had an opportunity
to talk to all the folks involved in the
Portuguese drug policy and it was really
interesting because what they're doing
is that when the police stop people for
drug possession or in one way or another
what they're doing is they're not
dealing with it through the criminal
justice system they're basically sending
them to a an advisory board that lies
outside the criminal justice system and
that board has no legal powers to coerce
people into treatment to coerce them
into jail it does not drug test people
but it basically aims to do is to
enhance people's consciousness around
what they're actually doing by taking
drugs and they try to provide them with
the services that they might need to try
to stop using drugs or get control of
their drug use and the interesting thing
is that here you have an approach that
seems soft minded or soft head in every
respect yet in fact the results in
Portugal are demonstrably positive that
in fact all sorts of you know criteria
like the number of people overdosing or
getting HIV or getting a wrestler being
involved in crime is basically staying
the same or dropping while in many other
countries is getting worse so Portugal
seems to me like an awfully good model
well I would say you're likely to see
ballot initiatives in California and
Colorado to legalize marijuana and I bet
50 50 that at least one of those win now
that's going to be a transformative
moment we saw that prop 19 on the ballot
in California last year you know that
didn't win but the fact that it got 46
and a half percent of the vote the fact
that they got more votes than Meg
Whitman did running for governor and she
spent a gazillion dollars more than
Carly Fiorina got the fact that sixty
percent of the people who voted for
jerry brown voted for it the fact that
it transformed the national discussion
the fact that when President barco and
Columbia can lead the summit of Latin
American presidents a few weeks before
Election Day in America the number one
subject on their agenda was what a prop
19 wins I'd say that we're making
remarkable momentum with respect to
America changing the marijuana laws I
say I'm more optimistic now than I've
ever been I mean the rapid
transformation and opinion around
legalizing marijuana from thirty-six
percent in favor in 2005 to 46 in favor
just a few months ago I think the
Momentum's with us I think that removing
marijuana from the criminal justice
system is something that can be attained
in America over the next decade I think
we can roll back to prison population
the bigger challenge is going to be can
we actually move into an entirely new
dialogue about how we accept the reality
that drugs are here to stay and figure
out more sensible and pragmatic ways of
dealing with them without relying on the
crutch of the criminal justice system
you